okay today I'm going to talk to you
about combustion we're going to look at
the difference between complete and
incomplete combustion so first of all
it's important to know that combustion
is the scientific term for burning and
in order for combustion to occur we need
to react with oxygen
now the first type of combustion we're
looking at is called complete combustion
complete combustion occurs when we have
plenty of oxygen a really good supply of
oxygen so we're gonna have a look at an
example now hydrocarbons make great
fuels because when we when they undergo
these combustion reactions they release
lots and lots of energy so a hydrocarbon
is just a molecule comprised only of
hydrogen and carbon so here's the
equation for complete combustion so when
we react to hydrocarbon with oxygen we
get two products we always get the same
things carbon dioxide and water and like
I said the whole purpose of this
reaction we could use this reaction is
in fuels to release loads of energy so
the this could the Hyder company could
use could be petrol in your car now I'm
just going to show you an example
underneath just to show an example of a
symbol equation so let's say we had a
hydrocarbon of methane contains only
carbon hydrogen we reacted with oxygen
and we get carbon dioxide and water I'll
just quickly balance this okay so as you
can see these are the two products we
always get during complete combustion
when there's a good supply of oxygen
remember carbon dioxide contributes
towards global warming so that is one of
the negative aspects of one of the
products here but it's preferable to
incomplete
student we'll see in a second now it
doesn't matter which hydrocarbon you
have it could be one with ten carbon
atoms instead we'll always get carbon
dioxide and water the only thing that
will differ is how many of each molecule
that will actually get so that's
complete combustion now we're going to
have a look at incomplete combustion so
it completely makes sense that complete
combustion is when we have plenty of
oxygen incomplete combustion occurs when
we have not enough oxygen an incomplete
combustion does not release as much
energy at all so incomplete combustion
is a little bit more tricky because we
don't always get exactly the same two
products I'm going to show you one
example of of incomplete combustion here
so let's say I have hydrocarbon again
again these are great fuels again we're
reacting with oxygen combustion needs
oxygen in order to occur now this time I
might have these products instead carbon
plus carbon monoxide plus water now in
reality during incomplete combustion
reactions I'm gonna have a mixture of
carbon dioxide carbon monoxide carbon
and water but the important thing is to
know that we do produce during
incomplete combustion these two
substances are produced here carbon
which is basically like certs it can
make it you know if it gets up into the
if it gets released it can go into
buildings and make them really black and
dirty and it can also cause respiratory
problems if inhaled by people now the
really serious serious product that we
need to know about is carbon monoxide
formula it's just Co if this is produced
then we can have some really
really serious consequences such as
fainting coma or death it's a poisonous
odorless colorless gas now the reason
why we need to know about this is let's
say you had it in your home you had a
faulty boiler and it wasn't doing
complete combustion though because it's
faulty it wasn't getting a plentiful
supply of oxygen carbon monoxide could
be produced and that would be if you
inhaled it could potentially be fatal
and kill you so this is why it's so
important to have a carbon monoxide
sensor in your house in case your
appliances undergo incomplete combustion
due to being faulty and the last thing
we really need to know about both of
these reactions is they are both
exothermic so they both release lots and
lots of energy and this is the reason
why combustion reactions occur during
fuels because when we burn fuel to
release the energy so that essentially
is the difference between complete
combustion and incomplete combustion
thank you